in trigonometry we started learning
about trigonometry with these things
called the trigonometric ratios there
are three of them what are they called
sine cos and tan and we learned them
like it's no coincidence
we learn them as you know aside in a
right angle triangle divided by another
side in a right angle triangle so which
pair of sides is sine opposite
hypotenuse cos is adjacent over
hypotenuse and tan is opposite alone I
think so all good we think of sine cos
and tan only as these ratios and only in
right angled triangles right angled
triangles only okay now that's kind of
what the trigonometric world the
trigonometric universe looked like to
you last year but this year what we've
tried to do is expand that okay so we've
done these things we introduced the unit
circle which is a bit brain reading at
the time but the point of doing that was
that you could deal with any angle right
if you're in right angled triangles
the only angles you ever deal with our
acute angles right because they're the
only angles you can fit in your right
angle triangle but when you have the
unit circle you've got you've got
quadrants now right you can spin round
and round around you're not limited from
naught to 90 you can get 90 to 180 or
180 270 all the way around
you can put in any angle you like right
so you go to your calculator and type
inside 135 and be like oh that's a theme
so you're outside these right angle
triangles we then introduce the sine of
the cosine rule I won't ask you to
rewrite them because you've got them in
your books already but the point of
introducing the sine and cosine rule was
to say not just any angles but now we
can deal with any triangles even if your
triangle doesn't have a right angle in
it as we need it up here if your
triangle doesn't have a right angle in
it no problem
the sine rule or the cosine rule can
find out any side any angle that you
need so now our world of trigonometry is
a bit broader you put any angle you want
in there you can put any triangle you
want and it's this last point under here
any triangle
we're going to introduce this air of a
triangle thing okay now we know how to
find the area of a triangle if you have
measurements we have a formula what's
the formula for the area of a triangle
you can all say it together right it's
1/2 base times height good can you write
that for me 1/2 base times height okay
now just like when we were theory
Demetri ratios this formula only works
in very specific circumstances right you
need to have a base and this height is
not just any height height is short for
perpendicular height very good so it's
like you can't always use this formula
if for example you have a triangle like
this and you've got like side lengths
but none of these are perpendicular to
any of the others well you're kind of
stuck you cannot use 1/2 base times
height but now that we know we can use
trigonometry to get away from
right-angled triangles we can use
trigonometry to find the area the area
of a triangle whatsoever ok so go ahead
draw this triangle you can see I've got
a little a little B little C they are
all opposite big a big B and big C ok so
if I wanted the perpendicular height
because I kind of need that for area at
the moment where would I put it there's
somewhere like here right so can you
enjoy yourself one of these lines by the
way if there's a right angle there at
the bottom this is not only the
perpendicular height we also give it the
special name of being called an altitude
like the altitude of the plane up in the
air it's perpendicular to the ground so
let's call this guy H ok now I'm going
to do a tricky that's related to how we
got the same rule ok if you have a look
at this angle here in this little
triangle on the left hand side okay I
can use some trig here to find out what
H is in terms of other lengths right for
example if I said sine of this angle
sine of angle C in this triangle over
here which is right angled right there's
right angles on both sides here which
parasites have I go and what ratio is it
it's opposite which is H over a which is
the hypotenuse can you write that for me
H over a but what this tells you is that
now you can state what H is on its own
by multiplying both sides of that
equation by something what would I
multiply both sides by have a look look
carefully because I've got H naught on
its own here it's got the a in the way
so I've got to multiply both sides by a
to get rid of it does that make sense
I know I've also switched sides as well
which might be a bit confusing but this
is great now that I know what H is I
don't have to write H anymore
I can just write that that's a sign see
does that make sense so I put in the Pro
numeral until I could find out what it
is and that's what algebra does and now
that I know what it is Bryan thank you
now that I know what H is I don't have
to write it anymore
so therefore the area is equal to well
it's still 1/2 base times height R 1/2
times the base which is B times the
height but I don't need to say height
anymore I can say a sine C right now
this is a bit backwards let's make this
nice and alphabetical just kind of rolls
off the tongue the half is still there
like it was from the original area of a
triangle formula but I can write this as
a B sine C even rhymes that's convenient
okay now just on this side here do you
remember I said we use the sine roll and
we also use the cosine rule they work in
any triangle as you like okay
can you help me remember the cosine rule
because there's something I want to draw
your attention to which is similar
between them I'll give you a clue it
starts with C squared very good it
starts off just like Pythagoras you
remember that but then there's like an
extra bit minus 2
a B cos C okay now do you remember I
point out to you that to find out C in a
non right-angled triangle you need to
know the other two sides and you need to
know one of the angles but not just any
angle which one yeah that's right see
how they match up right now have a look
over here do you see that this guy here
is an angle but it's not just any angle
have a look at where it is in relation
to the two lengths you're using here's a
and here's B so the angle you need is
the middle angle the specific name that
the fancy name is the included angle
right so just like with the cosine rule
C is the included angle between a and B
here for the area of a triangle formula
the new one you can't just pick any
angle this guy is the angle that's about
in between or included by length a and B
okay